BOSSMAN 99, THE ELECTRICAL HOME
IN PHOENIX.
TOWNS PUTS IT ON THE DECK.
OH!
BOSSMAN 99 JUST GOT FIRED!
>> Jim: THAT IGNITED THE CROWD
RIGHT THERE.
KARL-ANTHONY TOWNS LIT THE
MATCH.
THROWING IT DOWN.
WOW PLATES.
ONE NOW THERE ARE SOME WORDS
GOING ON.
>> Jim: THEY ARE GOING TO BACK
OFF ON THIS.
JAE CROWDER IS A TOUGH CUSTOMER,
LET ME TELL YOU.
WHEREVER HE HAS BEEN.
TOWNS IS NOT BACKING DOWN TO
ANYBODY.
THIS IS LIKE PLAYOFF BASKETBALL
RIGHT HERE.
MINNESOTA IS THROWING SOME
SERIOUS HAYMAKER'S AT THE
PHOENIX SUNS, PUNCTUATED BY
KARL-ANTHONY TOWNS.
>> Dave: AND THEN K.A.T.
POINTING AND SAYING, YEAH, I AM
IN JAE CROWDER SAID.
NASTY.
>> Jim: I DON'T KNOW HOW JAE
CROWDER DID NOT TAKE THE CHARGE
ON KARL.
HE WAS THERE, KAR